أجنبية
[موسيقى]
نفدت من الماء لا مزيد من
الماء
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] شعور غريب [موسيقى]
عندما لا يكون لديك ماء
تعرفه خاصة عندما يكون لديك أطفال حديثو الولادة
حتى  تم إصلاحه ، فهذا يعني أنه ليس
لدينا مياه جارية موثوقة على نطاق واسع ،
فهذا يعني أن المدينة لا تستطيع إنتاج ما يكفي من
المياه لمكافحة الحرائق
لغسل المراحيض بشكل موثوق وتلبية
الاحتياجات الضرورية الأخرى
[موسيقى]
تلعب السياسات العنصرية المتطرفة أو
وضعنا أمام الناس وحان
الوقت لأن نضع ذلك جانبًا
لم نعد قادرين على الاستمرار في ممارسة
الألعاب مع 175000 مقيم يعيشون هنا
في مدينة جاكسون وحدها
[موسيقى]
نحتاج إلى مساعدة فيدرالية  الإشراف ،
نحتاج إلى شيء ما
يحدث لأنه سيستمر لسنوات
سئم الناس من الركض إلى
المدن المجاورة التي لديها مياه نظيفة
للاستحمام فقط والذهاب إلى متاجر البقالة الخاصة بهم
واضطروا إلى الشراء من الماء
لأننا نملك  لا شيء نضعه في الاعتبار
لا أستطيع حتى أن أتحمل الانتقال من
جاكسون ، لذا يجب أن أبقى هنا وأتعامل
مع هذا
[الموسيقى]